les révérends bonsoir bonsoir nous
connaissait tout le monde alan enfin
pascal sevran lionel dutemple
marina foïs et pef voilà eric laurent
grand reporter spécialiste de politique
étrangère auteurs de plusieurs
best-sellers dont la guerre des bouches
et le monde secret de bouche qui ont été
adapté pour le cinéma et la télévision
avec un grand succès vous revenu
aujourd'hui avec la face cachée du 11
septembre publié chez plon alors si une
enquête que vous avez menées dans le
monde entier pendant dix mois vous avez
découvert une série de mensonges d'une
gravité inouïe on commence avec
l'arrestation de ben laden le 5 avril
2003 le général mayer ce chef d'état
major de l'armée américaine a déclaré
l'objectif n'a jamais été de capturer
ben laden
général myers qui est longue et le chef
d'état major de l'armée américaine a
fait cette déclaration d'ailleurs en
présence de donald rumsfeld le chef du
pentagone et il était d'ailleurs
extrêmement bas c'est évidemment après
il a démenti mais malheureusement le mal
était fait et évidemment c'est un
trouble et beaucoup de monde pourquoi le
général manière se déclare-t-il ça mais
moi mon avis pour une raison très simple
c'est que je crois qu'on ait fait
l'objectif n'avait jamais été attrapés
ben laden parce que parce que bon les
enjeux autour du 11 septembre sont
beaucoup plus trouble beaucoup plus
complexe a été d'ailleurs effectivement
l'objet d'une enquête et c'est vrai
qu'on voit se dessiner même avant le 11
septembre un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont mes plus que troublants qu'ils
soient vraiment dérangeante on apprend
par exemple en lisant votre bouquin que
ben laden n'a toujours pas été inculpé
pour le 11 septembre avoir ça c'est une
grande surprise je feuillette le dossier
de bin laden je regarde la fiche donc il
ya toutes les indications gauche et
marche avec une canne sans profession
enfin tout est répertorié je commettrais
surpris je me dis la fiche n'est pas
mise à jour je vérifie et effectivement
je m'aperçois que ni l'attentât contre
lui aux ss comme nous savez le american
women exactement en 2000 n'est
mentionnée est évidemment encore mois le
11 septembre je m'adresse donc os biya
et je demande à quelqu'un je connais au
contre-terrorisme os biya il me dit
écoutez c'est un vrai problème pour nous
parce que figurez-vous que le fbi avec
dépend du ministère de la justice
américain et depuis le 11 septembre 2001
monsieur john ashcroft quitte à lui très
proche collaborateur de bush n'a jamais
effectivement lancé d'avis de recherche
fédéral contre oussama ben laden alors
attendez le général maillard se déclare
que l'objectif n'a jamais été d'arrêter
ben laden vous découvrez qu aucun mandat
d'arrêt n'a été lancée par les états
unis contre ben laden pourquoi écoutez
les explications tient peut-être aussi
au fait qu' il existe des liens tout de
même extrêmement étroits
on peut dire plus étroits entre la
famille bush et la famille bin laden on
peut dire qu'il y a des liens d'affaires
entre les deux principales dynastie au
fond régnante c'est à dire d'une part la
dynastie bush et d'autre part aussi la
dynastie royale saoudienne
ce qui ce qui est frappant quand on
compte ou creuser au concours mon
enquête c'est de voir à quel point en
effet ses liens d'affaires ces réseaux
qui existent maintenant depuis 10 15 ans
prime sur évidemment l'intérêt général
et sur la logique politique bien entendu
alors dans votre bouquin il ya la
fameuse forteresse de bora bora je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez mais envoyer
sur lci il y avait un plan en coupe
envoyé deux montagnes qui était
entièrement creusé avec des ascenseurs
les départs de blindés tout était
extraordinaire j'ai mon bon voilà
c'était complètement james bond c'est
goldfinger à damas vous vous êtes amenés
dans cette fonction
abruzzes et à tora bora est donc
effectivement donc incompétents il fait
passer pour des temps des vieux couvert
et et à tora bora ce qui est tout à fait
étonnant c'est que je suis est jusqu'à
la maison de ben laden et c'est une
maison en torchis
et au dessus de laquelle tout en
longueur il ya huit pièces à peu près et
au dessus de laquelle il ya en effet
cinq petites grottes et je suis allée
danser sa grotte c5 grottes sont cinq
pauvres infractuosités de deux mètres de
profondeur de 80 cm de haut et qui
sentent mais terriblement lui rinne
ouais c'est tout y'a rien et quand j'ai
demandé aux gens qui prennent au bon
endroit
et quand j'ai demandé aux gens qui
m'accompagnent est l'équipe qui
m'accompagne et qui étaient des gens
d'ailleurs des afghans qui avaient
combattu bin laden et quand j'aurai dit
mais êtes vous allé à l'intérieur de la
grande grotte vous salle intérieure de
tora bora où étaient cachés bin laden
ont fait répéter plusieurs fois la
question est quand j'ai expliqué qu'en
effet il y avait effectivement en
occident une description extrait
marxiste le terrorisme mondial était
soi-disant dirigé exactement débutera
oui mais ils ont éclaté de rire ils ont
éclaté de rire ils ont trouvé que
j'étais un formidable plaisante
j'ai présenté un budget qu'il a un truc
parce qu'ils ont juste laisser les
toilettes ont fait un truc et c'est ça
le succès est tombé si vous avez
découvert on passe en revue tout ce que
vous avez découvert parce que vous avez
découvert des trucs il ya par exemple
les délits d'initiés c'est à dire qu'il
ya des gens qui étaient au courant du 11
septembre puisqu'il ya des transactions
financières exactement absolument
incassable qua non écoutez c'est tout à
fait incroyable c'est à dire que dans
les jours qui ont précédé le 11
septembre le 6 7 septembre et même le 10
septembre la veille des attentats on a
spéculé à la baisse ont acheté
massivement des actions des deux
compagnies aériennes dont les avions ont
été détournés pas d'autres compagnies
simplement united et american airlines
bon c'est à dire que cet effet avec un
cynisme incroyable ses doigts bon on a
misé effectivement donc sur la chute
évidemment de céder à un cours de ces
compagnies et ensuite le jour où la
bourse a été ouverte les gains ont été
considérables regard de plusieurs
dizaines de millions de dollars mais la
chose fascinante c'est que en remontant
un peu je dire on arrive effectivement
tout a été évidemment complètement caché
et par y compris par les autorités
américaine fbi a eu notamment la cia qui
n'ont jamais laissé filtrer
l'information mais j'ai réussi à
retrouver effectivement une banque
d'affaires qui a été effectué une des
banques effet acquis à effectuer donc
une partie de ses opérations et c'est
une banque d'affaires importantes qu est
une fille est aujourd'hui la deutsche
bank c'est avec ce drame alex prend
exactement et j'ai découvert
curieusement que l'ancien responsable de
cette banque pendant des années avait
démissionné juste avant d'ailleurs et
vous savez où il est maintenant il est
numéro 3 ne cia 1 il s'appelle belgique
en garde et c'était l'homme au sein de
la cia chargés de surveiller justement
tout est à nous toutes les situations
anormales sur les marchés financiers il
ya un truc ses désirs ses classes cia
surveille en temps réel 24 heures open
kart les marchés financiers et ils ont
pas ils ont ils ont rien dit qu en fait
monsieur crown garde qui était donc
l'homme en charge de cette opération n'a
rien vu rien entendu rien compris alors
que c'était évidemment les spécialistes
des finances qu'ils ont comme vous le
dites la sq de la possibilité d'opérer
en temps réel ouais alors il ya aussi la
l'identité des pirates de l'air on
connaît toujours pas en fait la
véritable identité des pirates de l'air
cinq d'entre eux ont usurpé l'identité
de personnes encore vivantes dites vous
dans votre livre est en fait ce que vous
dites c'est quand les mecs ont fait le
coup il n'est pas de tora bora là
c'était des tips étaient des saoudiens
qui s'entraînait sur les bases aériennes
américaines en fait oui et moi je suis
allé effectivement assisté à la dernière
réunion de la commission enquête le 17
juin donc à washington et j'ai posé la
question au vice président qui s'appelle
lee hamilton je lui ai dit êtes vous
vraiment sûr à 100% l'identité des
pirates de l'air et m'a répondu oui nous
sommes sûrs à 100% ce qui est absolument
faux car en effet comme vous le disiez
il ya cinq personnes 20 qui
effectivement donc ont vu leur il noté
usurpés par des pirates de l'air cinq
d'entre eux les gens sont manifestés
après l'attentât l'on dit écoutez je
suis désolé j'ai retrouvé ma photo j'ai
retrouvé en effet donc que j'ai retrouvé
mon identité ça n'est pas moi j'ai fait
une déclaration de perte ya maintenant
trois ans je vivais jamais quitté le
maroc la tunisie l'arabie saoudite le
yémen et la commission bancaire n'a pas
tenu exactement dans la même situation
encore une fois que effectivement donc
l'assassinât de kennedy avec la
commission warren la commission d'
enquête sur le 11 septembre a totalement
effacé toute trace en effet gênante les
délits d'initiés que vous évoquez ne
sont pas contenues dans le rapport la
commission les dirais-je les doutes sur
l'identité des pirates de l'air non plus
et il ya aussi un point extrêmement
important c'est la personnalité du
président de cette commission qui
s'appelle thomas skins et monsieur
thomas skins qui est un gouverneur du
new jersey ainsi que vient de le dire
j'ai un amis la famille bush a dans sa
biographie officielle un point qui a
totalement été effacés officiellement
c'est à dire on décrit en effet toutes
les activités caritatives auxquelles
s'est livrée mais on ne met un point
important c'est qu'il est le directeur
est le principal actionnaire d'un groupe
pétrolier qui s'appelle amerada hess et
ce groupe pétrolier à merano as a passé
des accords mais vraiment extrêmement
important avec une compagnie saoudienne
pétrolière aussi qui s'appelle delta oyl
et qui est dirigé par des membres de la
famille royale saoudienne et cette
compagnie commune donc à opérer
massivement dans les régions comme
l'amérique et le chef de la commission
denquête c'est le chef de la commission
d'enquêté la chose très intéressante
c'est que parmi effectivement ses
associés dans ce groupe pétrolier il y a
deux personnes qui sont deux saoudiens à
banquer saoudien et un autre à nos
milliardaires saoudiens des membres
aussi proche de la famille royale et qui
sont tous deux inculpés par les familles
aujourd'hui par des familles des
victimes c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur donc thomas skin enquête sur un
tragédie dont soi-disant les financiers
seraient en effet deux de ses anciens
associés mais ça n'a pas conduit du tout
à démissionner c'est une situation
incroyable il ya un truc incroyable
aussi c'est que les américains avaient
prévu que le world trade center puisse
être attaqué et le matin du 11 septembre
il y avait la défense aérienne qui
étaient en alerte depuis 6h du matin
tiens c'est pas un truc contrairement à
ce que nous a expliqué qu'il les a
surpris il pensait que ça pouvait
arriver et il avait même l'idée que ça
arrive ce jour là oui il y avait deux
exercices d'alert ce matin le 11
septembre au matin il y avait d'abord le
norad qui est chargé de surveiller
l'espace aérien de protéger l'espace
aérien américain qui était un état d'
alerte maximum les avions étaient déjà
effectué les chasseurs étaient déjà
effectivement encore l'air est alors la
chose plus troublante c'est ce que
lorsque les attentats ont été
effectivement donc connu donc on a lancé
des avions donc pour à la recherche et
surtout donc
pour essayer de récupérer donc les
appareils de ligne ne vous a fait
décoller de bases extrêmement éloignés
on aurait pu les faire décoller à côté
de washington ou à côté de new york où
il y avait des bases aériennes qui était
lui aussi en état d' alerte où est
l'avion aurait pu intercepter
immédiatement les avions ning sa peine
car vous allez partir de très loin et
surtout il a fait voler à des vitesses
extrêmement réduite la chose très
troublante c'est que ses avions de
chasse capable de voler à 2000 à l'heure
volet exactement à la vitesse des boeing
qui était censée rattraper
son effet
mais qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous voulez démontrer mairie de rien
démontré mot cg région du frioul
interviendront qu'ils ont laissé deux
boeing entrer dans des tours plutôt que
de les intercepter alors qu'il pouvait
le faire si vous êtes en train de dire
qu'il y a eu des transactions faites le
dise cette transaction ne sont pas
toutes anonyme on doit pouvoir remonter
d'étrangers si j'aimerais côté dit si
vous avez le moindre numéro je vous
encourage à le faire et si tout ce que
vous avez dans votre livre dans votre
enquête fait je vous encourage à passer
le livre très rapidement à john kerry
qui le fera savoir dans les dix jours à
l'amérique entière pour qu'enfin ce mec
s'en aille bouge pas ce qu'il va être
réélu là mais aussi oui il doit
absolument le faire passer j'ai vu qu'un
nommé je vous dire mieux le film tire
effectivement de mes livres précédents
et circulent sur des sites guérit
maintenant et le matin du 11 septembre
le matin du 11 septembre comme disait
était en état d' alerte maximum et d'une
part et y avait aussi un autre exercice
d' alerte qui était très troublant c'est
à dire l' agence de renseignement
américaine n'a plus la plus secrète qui
s'appelle généraux et qui contrôle tous
les satellites espions américains à
travers le monde avait prévu un exercice
d' alerte qui prévoyait justement donc
un attentat un avion utilisés comme
cibles volantes s'écrasant sur le siège
de cette agence est la chose la plus
étonnante encore c'est que le pentagone
avait lui aussi prévu plusieurs
exercices dallaire de ce genre et il y
avait parmi les experts qui
travaillaient sur ce programme il y
avait un homme qui s'appelait cheat
birmingham c'était un ancien pilote de
la navy et quand il avait quitté and
evil avec hot tuna travaille comme
expert pour le pentagone est tout autre
à bien comme expert pour le pentagone il
était commandant de bord à american
airlines et vous savez où il était le
matin du 11 septembre il était à bord ou
thé aux commandes du vol american
airlines 77 qui s'est écrasé sur le
pentagone
alors celui là il paraît qu'il n'a pas
existé alors non mais c'est un truc de
fou parce qu'il ya d'autres choses vous
confirmer par exemple qu'après le
11-septembre le ciel américain était
interdit évidemment au vol non militaire
disons mais pas aux membres de la
famille ben laden il ya 140 personnes la
famille ben laden vous confirmer parce
que ça on l'a dit et vous confirmez oui
on bien sûr il ya 140 personnes de la
famille ben laden et de la famille
royale saoudienne qui ont pu quitter les
états unis malgré la fermeture du ciel
oui mais il ya un autre fait troublant
parce parmi les 140 personnes qu'on a
fait partir il y avait un personnage un
nom de la famille assad yen qui était le
fils du prince salman le prince salman
est un des frères du roi d'arabie
saoudite et ce fils et prince salman qui
s'appelle prince fahd b soul man etc et
qui est des deux responsables du plus
grand groupe de presse saoudienne et
était à lexington dans le kentucky où il
était en train d'acheter parce qu'ils
avaient des écuries de courses en train
d'acheter plusieurs chevaux donc il est
reparti en arabie saoudite et quelques
mois plus tard les américains ont arrêté
donc un des principaux adjoints de bin
laden qui s'appelle zoubaydah et la
chose est assez étonnante et subban a
été arrêté au pakistan les américains
donc l'ont interrogé longuement et
ensuite de transférer sur une base
américaine donc en afghanistan et là ils
ont maquillé la base américaine de façon
à ce que l'homme ait l'impression de se
retrouver effectivement dans une prison
saoudienne il y avait deux deux hommes
des forces spéciales américaines donc
deux arabes américains qui étaient
chargés de l'interroger avec des
uniformes saoudien est plutôt qu'être
paniqués ils auraient dû être panique à
l'idée se retrouve en arabie saoudite il
a vraiment mais exulter et il s'est
penché dans les deux hommes et l'arabie
écouté il a redonné de numéroter sony
dit écoute et appeler immédiatement on
vous dira ce qu'il faut faire et là
évidemment les américains ont vérifié et
les deux numéros de téléphone étaient
les numéros de téléphone de ce fameux
prince le prince musulmane et c'est bon
et sur le coup les américains n'y
croient pas évidemment se disent en
effet non c'est une désinformation et on
revient avec ce fameux responsable d'al
qaïda et on lui dit tu sais tu risque
gros parce que en effet donc accusé ment
de la famille royale saoudienne tu vas
avoir été tranchée et c'est une autre
dit mais n'en attendait une arrière vos
prix et pendant dix minutes pendant 10
minutes il va se livrer à une confession
qui va essayer des américains mais
stupéfait c'est à il dit écoutez n'est
pas seulement lui et il cite les noms de
trois autres princes et lille étaient au
courant ils ont financé une partie des
attentats il savait pas quand il aurait
lieu ils savaient pas où ils auraient
lieu simplement sa seule chose et il
ajoute un cinquième nom et qui est le
responsable qui est le nom du
responsable de de l'armée de l'air
pakistanaise le maréchal mire et la
chose tout à fait étonnante c'est que
personne n'est évidemment à washington
de protest n'adresse un mois de
protestation donc aux saoudiens et
curieusement trois mois plus tard fameux
prince femme meurt d'une crise cardiaque
absolument expliqué 43 ans immédiatement
après le lendemain donc son cousin qui
était aussi impliqué donc se rendait à
ses obsèques sur la route entre djeddah
et riyadh accident de voiture mortel et
le troisième cerise sur le gâteau tout
de même le troisième prince donc
impliquer compromis meurt vous savez de
quoi à 70km de ryad il meurt de soif
dans le désert communiqué officiel et
quant au dernier donc effectivement le
maréchal mire le responsable pakistanais
son avion explosera en plein vol de
façon inexpliquée il n'y aura jamais
d'enquêté officielle je sais ce que
c'est c'est le scénario de la saison 4
de 24 heures qui passent sur cale
alors
exit par exemple qu'il serait possible
que des fonds saoudiens
possède des entreprises je dirais
d'informatique d'entreprise
technologique américaine qui sont en
liaison avec la cia et le fbi à esther
qu'en fait il serait à l'intérieur du
truc c'est une réalité et je dire tout
ce qui est dans le livre totalement
étayé il ya le cas d'un milliardaire
saoudien qui s'appelle monsieur al qadi
qui est aujourd'hui un homme classé sur
la liste des 39 financier du terrorisme
donc international et monsieur al qadi
qui est donc un homme qui se livre non
seulement au commerce de diamants et
d'or qui sont en effet il faut bien le
dire les deux manne essentielle oui
d'al-qaïda possède une société de haute
technologie qui s'appelle pitt est qu
installer donc légitimement donc dans le
massachusetts et qui a comme principaux
clients les principales agences de
renseignement américaines c'est à dire
le fbi à elle seule en tête voilà le fbi
travaille sur de l'informatique sur des
souliers logiciel de matane le saoudien
voilà qui leur vendent le matos c'est
pas grave mais c est ce qu ils ont aussi
quand ils le revendent bien sûr blessure
brillent et garder un double des clés
c'est ce que dit eric lange il ya un
truc énorme et là effectivement
c'est très excusez moi mais c'est très
thierry meyssan là quand même à vous dit
et si les services secrets israéliens
avaient été au courant et s'ils avaient
laissé faire parce que ça a aidé leur
cause je dis simplement et c'est un fait
avéré qu'il y avait en effet 60
israéliens qui étaient logés comme on
dit en termes de métier juste à
proximité donc des terroristes du 11
septembre où théo risotto dans plusieurs
endroits la floride aux endroits où où
les soi disant terroristes étaient
censés en effet s'entraîner et la chose
très troublantes avec donc c'est que le
ce la cia le fbi a ils les ont arrêtés
les ont longuement interrogé ou la
preuve en effet qu'il s'agissait
d'agents du mossad et la chose tout à
fait étonnante là aussi
c'est qu'il ya l'épisode je dirais qui a
été repris dans toute la presse
israélienne a juste au moment où les
tours s'effondrent et ça c'est quand
même très très tout à fait étonnant long
autour ces fronts il ya une femme qui
est en train de regarder le spectacle de
cette tragédie et qui voit trois jeunes
hommes qui sont en train de sauter de
joie assis sur les toits naumann blanc
donc elle avertit la police devant
évidemment leur attitude extrêmement
suspecte est en effet la police les
arrête et ils sont quatre à l'intérieur
et on découvre qu'ils sont israéliens et
l'un d'eux dit d'ailleurs écouter nous
sommes pas votre problème
votre problème vos problèmes sont nos
problèmes et vous de vos problèmes sont
les palestiniens la cia et les services
de contre-espionnage donc les interroge
on les met en prison est serré et on
s'aperçoit que sont les agents du mossad
travaillant sous couverture pour une
société qui s'appelle urban moving et
qui nous étaient chargés de surveiller
les islamistes radicaux pour moi là et
quand ils reviendront donc sur en israël
la presse la presse israélienne ne sera
la première à s'indigner de leur
comportement en disant qu'ils ont eu un
comportement absolument choquant car on
retrouvera dans le vin des photos d'eux
l'une d'elle notamment où on voit comme
dans un concert d'ailleurs de rock de
pop la deux avec les tours en train de
s'effondrer au fond en train d'allumer
donc à briquet voilà vous pensez que le
mossad était au courant de l'attentât du
world trade center le génie perkins a
été au cours des autres sans terre les
étaliers mais il ya un moment faut se
mouiller parce que quand on dit c'est
vrai qu'à la fin il faut dire non gel
intime conviction car elles n'ont pas
non non non à une conviction et des
israéliens probablement d'ailleurs il ya
un journal je cite un journal juif
respecter new york qui s'appelle forward
et qu'il y en ait fait donc on savait
que ces gens donc les quatre les quatre
jeunes israéliens arrêtés étaient des
agents travaillant pour le mossad bien
sûr c'est une chose qui est tout à fait
reconnu mais vous savez ce que je
raconte aussi c'est que l'israël se
livrent à des activités d'espionnage aux
états unis extrêmement non mais je
raconte dans le livre et à plusieurs
reprises ont espionné la maison blanche
serait et au moment même où ils ont
effectué les branchements et chaque fois
qu'un président américain notamment le
dernier en date clinton décroché son
téléphone il y avait effectivement donc
un transfert de la communication sur tel
aviv ou jérusalem un étonnant alors vous
confirmez ce qui était donnée jusqu'ici
comme une grosse intox c'est l'histoire
des messages avertissant les employés
vous parlez de la société odigo est ce
c'est vrai ça bien sûr c'est vrai ça
s'est passé comme engrais ça s'est passé
très simplement aux 10 go est une
société de serveurs installés en israël
avec eux donc
un certain nombre n'est fait donc deux
succursales aux états unis et deux
agents de fans de deux responsables du
odigo ont reçu un message deux heures
avant les faits donc la suite des tours
alors la teneur de messages
effectivement n'est pas très claires
j'ai un peu mais c'était un message
avertissant en effet de l'imminence à 10
ans des attentats et les responsables de
la coupe de la firme aux digues aux lois
immédiatement transféré donc aux
responsables israéliens et non le
transfert est également haut responsable
américain mais vous avez une chose très
intéressante dans l'histoire du world
trade center et de l'effondrement du
contrat de santerre vous pour vous
parlais tout à l'heure c'est que on a
découvert beaucoup mieux parce que vous
dites ou il faut trouver des traces on
va trouver les traces c'est ça qui est
tout à fait étonnant c'est à dire que au
fond là l'effondrement des tours
d'ivoire présenté a été le crime parfait
j'ai évidemment non seulement en raison
du nombre de victimes mais pour ce
concert les transactions financières car
on avait constaté qu'il y avait à un
niveau extraordinairement élevé de
transactions qui s'opérait au moment
juste avant l'attaqué contre les tours
et au moment-même d'ailleurs où les
tours étaient en train de brûler ses
dettes des ordinateurs fonctionner les
transactions financières était beaucoup
plus élevé que la moyenne à l'intérieur
des volontaires bien sûr moment même et
immédiatement immédiatement après lâcher
a pu immédiatement après la chute des
tours d'octobre un certain nombre de
compagnies qui sont les sociétés de
crédit des sociétés financières se sont
réunis en poule pour essayer en effet
donc et d'exhumer un certain nombre de
disques durs de messer de ses
ordinateurs et ils ont confié
effectivement donc l'analyse de ces
disques durs à une société allemande qui
s'appelle asus des convard donc et qui
est un procédé de systèmes par laser qui
permet en effet de relire en effet sur
des disques de l'une des digues ce que
très très endommagée et le responsable
de cette fille en convard a fait un aveu
un cela veut il a dit ce qui vraiment ce
qui apparaît à la lecture et la
découverte de ces informations c'est un
gigantesque des initiés il a dit je
pense qu'on sera effectivement qui sont
les responsables et le fbi a bloqué les
choses un mot et parce que la société a
accepté de collaborer avec eux et à
partir de là tout a été complètement
c'est l'omerta c'est la loi du silence
autour du 11 septembre c'est ça qui est
tout à fait rare voilà la dernière chose
c'est bourré de scoop son bouquin c'est
vraiment incroyable
dernière chose la traduction des
cassettes de ben laden
dans lesquelles ils revendiquent les
attentats contre le world trade center
et vous dit que finalement la traduction
quand on fait les américains n'est pas
exact il ya eu énormément de
casteljaloux qatar al jazira justement
possédant mode et la pisse des cassettes
donc de début de laden il ya une
cassette qui est très troublante parce
que en effet américains disent avoir
trouvé à djalalabad donc la ville
d'afghanistan où je suis allé et les
afghans les responsables afghans que
j'ai vu disent qu'on n'a jamais trouvé
de cassettes labo la date que donnent
les américains n'est pas la bonne et
ensuite cette cassette est resté pendant
deux mois donc entre les mains donc des
responsables américains et ensuite bush
a décidé au mois de décembre donc fin
décembre de la diffuser et simplement
lorsqu'on regarde donc la casse est
originale en arabe est la traduction qui
a été fait ensuite on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya des ajouts qui a des partis dans la
partie originale râble complètement
inaudible qui ont été donc transformé
sur lequel on a apporté un traitement un
certain nombre de deux mots d'éléments
de phrases et ses acquis maintenant on a
confirmé en effet donc la responsabilité
de ben laden ce qui fait qu ensuite ben
laden est allé directement donné ses
cassettes al jazira pour couronner ce
verdict est la traduction que je pense
qu'il a voulu effectivement éviter on a
un qu'à l'avenir les choses puissent lui
échapper en terme d'image oui comment
vous expliquer alors que ben laden les
revendique c'est non c'est à 30 ans et
non non aux minarets n'a jamais
revendiqué les attentats la case où
justement on le voit avec oui mais
justement c'est celle de nous parler ses
succès dont paris et seulement des trucs
et celle là est complètement
retouchée je n'y a pas truquée
complètement retoucher les autres
cassettes et qui arrive après n'évoque
pas directement les attentats à chaque
fois bin laden dire les faits je suis
heureux en effet c'est un acte admirable
et c'est sur des martyrs extraordinaire
à mes huit même personnellement non et
au très haut débit entre kiel et qui
pensait pas que les deux tours allait
s'effondrer oui mais justement c'est
cette la c7 cassel un milieu et qu'est
ce qu'on dit alors justement il se lâche
à la trad on croyait la traduise
réellement c'est une tâche est le beau
gars
quand vous savez tout ça écoutez moi je
crois que c'est très simple je crois
qu'il faut enquêter c'est tout remonter
les files c'est tout bravo eric
alors éric j'ai tjrs et vous étiez sur
le terrain on va accueillir maintenant
quelqu'un qui était encore plus proche
du terrain c'est le sergent chef adam a
[Musique]
bonjour le sergent chef adam à vous êtes
un soldat des forces spéciales
vous êtes un béret vert ah oui
je suis aussi membre de la garde
nationale alors on mai 2002 vous avez
été envoyés en afghanistan pour traquer
les membres d'al-qaida justement et vous
êtes revenu avec un livre coécrit avec
le capitaine alan hatch qui s'appelle se
livre sur les traces d'al qaïda c'est
publié chez albin édition voilà alors
c'est un témoignage de deux membres des
forces spéciales alors dès votre arrivée
en afghanistan vous découvrez des
problèmes de logistique des problèmes de
sécurité alors vous dites qui a passé de
soldat ça c'est quelque chose de très
important dans votre livre il ya qu'à
l'état major où il ya un nombre
suffisant de militaires mais vous dans
l'action quotidienne il ya très très peu
de soldats par rapport à ce qu'il a à
faire
l'afghanistan c'est à peu près la taille
du texas donc il ya des déserts des
montagnes très haute du désert aride pas
de rôlistes par l'infrastructure
exactement une situation très difficile
et à l'époque quand j'étais sur place il
y avait peut-être environ deux mille
hommes sur place sur le terrain en
dehors des camps militaires et donc
donc on était très peu c'est clair mais
en plus au niveau du quartier général il
y avait énormément de bureaucratie et à
tel point qu'il était difficile
d'obtenir des approbations pour tout
simplement sortir de la base et pour
aller sur le terrain justement à ce qui
est très étonnant aussi c'est que le
matériel moderne n'est pas utilisée par
exemple un moment vous réclamez des
hélicoptères et on vous dit qu'un appât
il ya plein d'hélicoptères tout neufs
comme ça qui sont sur un tarmac c'est
incroyable ça
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
quand on demandait du soutien et rien
pour les quelque part on ne pouvait pas
aller en voiture est bien ce moment là
on ne répondait n'écoutez ya pas
d'hélicoptère disponibles puis ensuite
vous sortiez du bâtiment tout simplement
et vous regardiez que vous voyez que des
hélicoptères toute une série
d'hélicoptères des des hélicoptères
qu'on aurait pu utiliser et donc ce
qu'il fallait qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
n'utilise ce dont on disposait à savoir
des camions et des 4 4 voilà déjà se
pose la question que pose son livre
c'est à dire est ce que tout ça c'est
l'incompétence de l'armée américaine ou
est-ce qu'au contraire il ya une volonté
de ne pas attraper des mecs parce que
bon puis surtout c'est peut-être pas la
vraie guerre là tout de suite on va la
faire parce qu'on est obligé de passer
par là est la vraie guerre est l'épousé
a grandi minutes alors le plus
incroyable dans votre bouquin c'est
l'incapacité à attraper les terroristes
par exemple le mot la hausse maniquet le
numéro un des militaires talibans il a
été détenu quinze jours à la base de
kandahar après que vous l'ayez à mener
et et avant son transfert vers une
prison afghane et ensuite il a acheté
son évasion pour cent cinquante mille
dollars
en liquide et il est parti au pakistan
la bon certes c'est une source de
frustration extrême pour niveau bien
dire en fait nous on était habillé en
portaient des burqas et on devait se
déplacer on étaient déguisés en femmes
afghanes
donc on a mis nos risques en vie et on a
fini par rattraper à ce type qui était
un type terrible qui était responsable
de la mort de biens des personnes et
comme je vous le disais donc une fois
qu'on attrape quelqu'un a bien bien
évidemment on le passe au grill on veut
l'entendre ensuite c'est fini mais après
quand on a entendu qu'ils avaient été
relâchés il ya un accord un afghan qui
est venu nous voir nous et ils sévissent
pas possible on n'a pas relâché ce type
c'est complètement incroyable s'accroît
alors le mollah omar c'est pareil c'est
à dire qu'ils étaient positionnés par
satellite vous dites on avait son numéro
de portable on avait sans le numéro de
sa toyota on avait le nom de son
chauffeur on avait tout l'été
complètement repérer et et aucune armée
n'était allait s'emparer de lui
nous a dit
là où on pensa qu'il était et s'il a
réussi à survivre aussi longtemps c'est
tout simplement parce qu'il se déplaçait
rapidement ils passaient jamais plus
d'un jour ne manquent pas et on nous a
dit qu ils le pensaient qu'ils savaient
là ils étaient mes problèmes c'était que
cet endroit n'était pas accessible en
voiture et donc il a fallu qu'on rendra
la base et qu'on demande des
hélicoptères est donc là comme je vous
disais les hélicoptères étaient alignés
indisponible et donc ils ne nous ont
jamais dit non mais en fait il ne veut
jamais dit oui non plus pendant et ça a
duré plusieurs jours et puis voilà alors
la question qu'il se pose voilà encore
une fois simple cafouillage de l'armée
ou alors volonté d'attendre les
élections américaines pour arrêter le
mollah omar ben laden mais n'en ont ni
aux élections américaines donc c'est pas
ça je crois qu'on n'a aucune envie
d'attraper bin laden je pense que on
sait où il est on sait à peu près où il
est mais il est une telle représentation
de dire symbolique de la menace
terroriste que la trappe éprouveraient
au fond on est en mesure de juguler
cette menace terroriste et je crois que
personne ne le souhaite ne serait ce que
par exemple quand on voit par exemple à
tora bora on a laissé partir je veux
dire lorsqu'on annonce l attaque
terrestre contre tora bora donc en
décembre 2001 on sait déjà maintenant
aussi milanais étaient déjà partis et on
n'avait pas du tout fermé la frontière
avec le pakistan
l'ate a pris un coup sur la tête là ce
soir
oui et non parce que en fait on imagine
toujours le pire est vachement rencontre
qu'il faut multiplier par 1000 et qu'on
est encore en dessous de la vérité
tout le respect que je vous dois vous
avez complètement raison ça veut dire ce
que ça peut apporter plus de preuves que
ça tu nous décrit un
c'est brian
écoutez moi je peux vous dire c'est que
si je savais où il était planquée moi
j'irai le chercher ça ne fait aucun
doute
je pense qu'il est encore en vie mais je
pense qu'il est quelque part au pakistan
et je pense qu en fait le truc c'est
qu'on n'a pas envie de rentrer au
pakistan ce bien merci en tous les cas
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci à la
mairie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu